der ballermann und magaluf sind dicht
der grund dafür touristen hatten dort
wild und hemmungslos gefeiert und das
ohne abstände und ohne masken
wir konnten mit dem tourismusminister
der balearen jaguar sprechen und haben
ihn unter anderem gefragt was er zu der
aussage von jens spahn sagt dass
mallorca das neue äste werden könnte
es ist so wir leben vom tourismus und
wir wollen auch dass touristen kommen
aber wenn diejenigen kommen die unsere
gesundheit gefährden wollen wir nicht
dass diese art des tourismus dieses jahr
oder in zukunft kommt es gab hier
verhaltensweisen von denen ich nicht
glaube dass das auch in ihren
herkunftsländern so passiert ich glaube
nicht dass sie sich so in ihren
heimatländern sind nehmen warum soll man
sich dann hier also so benehmen
warum muss man hierher kommen und auf
autos rum springen oder sich
alkoholische getränke teilen
warum sollten wir so etwas akzeptieren
wir sind ein reiseziel mit qualität und
bieten dem tourismus ein großartiges
angebot
aber es gibt ein paar aktivitäten die
dieses jahr eingeschränkt werden und ja
ich habe gesagt dass wir keine touristen
oder sozial bewusstsein mehr wollen und
ich war mir auch bewusst was ich sage
und auch was es bedeutet aber ich glaube
auch dass die deutsche regierung sehr
klar gesprochen hat sie wollen ja selbst
nicht dass die touristen hier so etwas
machen wir haben wochenende geschehen
weil sie bei ihrer rückkehr auch
potenziell gefährden können deswegen
glaube ich dass uns allen bewusst ist
dass der tourismus dieses jahr ein
anderer sein muss sowohl in den ländern
die touristen entsenden als auch den
ländern die tourismus empfangen wenn
regierungen eine klare sprache sprechen
und auch überzeugen ist es weil ein
echtes gesundheitsrisiko besteht was die
leute einfach verstehen und annehmen
müssen
man muss handeln wenn ein derartiger
egoismus entsteht und damit die
bevölkerung gefährdet wird man muss eine
individuelle verantwortung haben um das
kollektiv zu schützen
so sollte jeder bürger denken jedes mal
wenn er auf der straße geht ob in seiner
stadt in seinem land oder einem anderen
land
ich denke die epidemiologische situation
in der wir uns gerade auf den balearen
befinden ist besser als die in
deutschland
das heißt die deutschen touristen sind
wegen unserer situation hier viel
sicherer als in ihrem heimatland und das
garantiert auch sicherheit
außerdem haben wir ein sehr gutes
öffentliches und privates
gesundheitssystem mit hoher qualität
ich glaube auch nicht dass wir in
derselben situation sind wie ischgl
aber wir sind auch besorgt dass es jetzt
hier zu ausbrüchen kommen könnte dieses
risiko dürfen wir nicht eingehen
und das natürlich nicht nur weil dies
ein minister aus einem anderen land
sondern wir weder die touristen noch
unsere bevölkerung gefährden wollen wir
haben bereits sehr strenge maßnahmen
ergriffen damit wir jetzt in dieser
großen epidemiologischen situation sind
wir sind in europa eines der gebiete mit
den wenigsten fallzahlen und wir wollen
auch dass das so bleibt und das ist auch
gerade unsere stärke dass wir ein
sicheres reiseziel sind
ich sage nochmal verhalten was die
gesundheit oder sicherheit gefährdet
werden wir nicht tolerieren und ich
glaube die regierung hat es mit den
maßnahmen auch deutlich gemacht dass wir
so ein verhalten nicht